và bà trung quốc và bà ký stand của bộ sang kiến năm điểm.
Nhằm thúc đẩy hoa bình tại Trung Đông,
chứ bất cả những giúp đột quốc tức tụi lâu tháng.
Theo anh tin, anh ở đối lâu, để xuất đưa ra sau của quốc đam,
giống hoại trung quốc vương nghi và phó thu tướng kiêm hoại trường và ký stand,
mua hành mắt, ý xe đà tại bắt kinh.
Sang kiến kêu hỏi các bên dân quan lưu mắn như lập tất,
hồi động đàn phán hoa bình bảo vệ sinh thường và các cơ sở hạ tận phi của sử.
Đông thơi bảo đam anh điện các tuyến hành hải của tế là biệt lấy biển thông ốt,
tế bố chung nhận mạnh đối th ngoại vòng hội dào,
là con đường khả thí duy nhất để giải quyết của sử dụng,
cùng với việc tưởng thủ hiểm chương li được quốc và luật pháp của tế.
Đồng thấy nể giễn ra chung bố cảnh và ký stand,
đồng hơi trọng chung dân trong các của tế xung giám tiếm giống Mỹ và yên văn,
nhằm hạnh nghiệp tăng thằng khu dực.
Tuy nhiên, thông ồn tỷ đi văn được hãng els Azure Rang Rang Ngại,
tế Rang bài tỏ hôm hài lòng mối sang kiến,
giòn thiếu tham vấn chức khi cộng bố,
chứ rằng các của gia lình quan tân được cho đủ chấp,
đối với những để gió thành hủ chực tiếp để lửa ít ăn điện khu được.